hi this Matt Welch for recent TV I'm at
Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and I'm here
with fox news commentator Juan Williams
I was just talking about school choice
reform tell us a little bit how you
first came into the school choice
movements or ideas and why when did the
light bulb go off you know the light
bulb went off for me in the 90s when I
started to understand the crisis
especially in big city public schools
the high dropout rate especially for
vulnerable populations and that sounds
so amorphous let me just be put some
meat on the bone swear i'm talking about
poor children talking especially about
immigrant kids and minority kids and
these are kids who in some way embody
the spirit of belief in America you'd be
surprised how patriotic and they watch a
lot of TV because oftentimes they're you
know they're at home a lot they don't
have money they want to succeed they
want to be somebody and that you know
what the schools aren't meeting the
needs the schools freedom like they are
throwaway children like there to be
discarded and those teachers they'll
talk about you know what this kid really
can't succeed and then you know who
picked up on this and really caught my
imagination which President Bush when he
talked about the bigotry of low
expectations bigotry that's right yes I
mean and you think about that now
there's a president they love you said
well he's a conservative into a second
here he is expressing a deep heartfelt
compassionate concern about America's
children of all color particularly those
who are locked into failing schools and
what was the reaction from the school
unions and the school community oh no no
problem here why are you bothering us I
mean it's just an outrage it is the
outrage of our time that's why i think
it's the civil rights issue of our time
to assure that parents and children have
some choice that allows them to get a
quality education now we're in a moment
where there's a lot of documentaries
that have come and it feels like there's
a lot of momentum on the side of school
reform yet it's not quite happening who
needs to be reached in this debate that
isn't being reached or isn't being
engaged so far well I think one thing
that always amazes me is that so many of
the parents of these children who are
locked into these failing schools are
not in the store
I just don't understand it at times and
what I've been told by superintendents
that I've asked about it is you know
what they feel they don't have a choice
and therefore they're going to not want
to say to their child you know what my
daughter my daughter my son you go to a
bad school and there's just not much
hope what's going to happen to you
coming out of that school so they don't
say anything they don't raise their
voices if we could get them to raise
their voices and how do you get them to
raise their voices these are people who
say they don't have a choice they don't
want to speak badly of a school that
their child has to attend the answer is
give them a choice give them a choice
that would allow them to say I'm going
to decide where my child goes and if
that schools not working for my child I
have a choice to move on that's the
answer and I just it's to me glaring
it's obvious and it's compelling and
that's why I'm speaking about it you
used to work at MPR now you work at fox
news iya fans in both sort of sides
which has been more receptive to school
choice ideas in your experience Oh
without a doubt the rights more
receptive to school choice because you
know a lot of this then becomes
political and that you know this is the
part of it that can become problematic
for someone like me whose job is to
analyze politics I'm not here to say one
sides right or one size wrong in terms
of politics but it's clear that the
union's put money into Democrats who
then support the existing the status quo
when it comes to failing schools and
Republicans are saying wait a second why
is it that Democratic politicians are
fed by unions who benefit from public
taxpayer dollars so there is a
connection here and there's corruption
in this whole system in my opinion but
Republicans are the ones who because
they are negatively affected by it are
jumping up and screaming bloody murder
last question what do you see happening
the next five years are you optimistic
where's it going to break what's
happening oh I I'm optimistic and I you
know what I believe that if you have an
honest discussion of this it's just so
overwhelming we just look at the numbers
you look right now there's that scandal
in Atlanta and elsewhere over test
scores being faked you look at the
dropout rate in this country how many
children are not getting out of high
school at a time of global economic
competition competition for jobs nine
percent unemployment how can you say to
so many young people
so you don't need a high school
education we're not going to give you
the opportunity to make us something to
make something of yourself in America I
think it's a condemnation of America and
I think that it's contrary to the
American spirit so no I I tend to be
very optimistic that this is a breakout
issue that we're on the verge of us what
I call or described to you earlier as
this these civil rights issue the
political issue of the 21st century
thank you very much with one Williams
I'm Matt Welch for reason TV